.
* Windrauschen, helle Liegeklänge *
(Mann) Im ersten Moment dachte ich,
es sei ein schlechter Witz,
ein Zufall.
Das war mein erster Gedanke.
Ich dachte: "In Wuhan
war ich schon mal, ich kenne es."
Jetzt kennen es plötzlich alle.
Vorher kannte es niemand.
* Ausschnitte aus den News *
... rassicurano:
la misteriosa polmonite virale.
- La mystérieuse maladie
contractée par 59 patients
dans le centre de la Chine
serait causée par un nouveau virus.
... sono 59 le persone ...
- Die Gesundheitsorganisation WHO
steht mit den chinesischen Behörden
in Kontakt
wegen mehrerer Dutzend Fälle
einer Lungenkrankheit.
... grossen Fischmarkt
in der Millionenstadt Wuhan.
La maladie est apparue le mois der-
nier dans la grande ville de Wuhan.
(Mann) Als wir nach Wuhan reisten,
mussten wir die Stadt
auf der Karte erst mal finden.
Ein halbes Jahr später wusste jeder
Mensch der Welt, wo Wuhan liegt.
Diese Dimensionen wurden mir
erst später zu Hause bewusst,
was es auslöste, dass wir
genau in dieser Stadt waren.
* Sich überlagernde Newsausschnitte
zum Coronavirus *
* Pulsierende, düstere Klänge *
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
(Mann, italienisch)
Am ersten Januarwochenende
brachte ich meine Tochter
zum Tanzunterricht.
Das Einkaufszentrum,
in dem sich die Tanzschule befindet,
war ganz verlassen - menschenleer.
Zu diesem Zeitpunkt
kamen die ersten Informationen:
"Seid vorsichtig. Wenn ihr aus
dem Haus geht, tragt eine Maske."
"Berührt nichts.
Es gibt wohl ein neues Virus."
Innerhalb kurzer Zeit
wurde dieses Virus
als das neue SARS bezeichnet.
Es ist Anfang Januar 2020.
Dem in Wuhan lebenden Italiener
Lorenzo Mastrotto wird klar,
dass in der Metropole
ein mysteriöses Virus grassiert.
Am 5. Januar gibt die WHO auf Veran-
lassung Chinas offiziell bekannt,
dass in der Region Wuhan
Fälle von Lungenentzündungen unbe-
kannten Ursprungs aufgetreten sind.
Am 23. Januar fordert Wuhan
die gesamte Bevölkerung auf,
zu Hause zu bleiben.
Es wird ein Lockdown verhängt.
Ein Begriff, den wenige Wochen später
auch Europa und die Schweiz
kennenlernen werden.
Es ist der Beginn
eines traurigen Kapitels,
das in die Geschichte eingehen wird.
* Gedämpfte Geräusche, Atmen *
Der Tag
hatte wie jeder andere begonnen,
ein Arbeitstag
in einem Vorstadtspital.
Ich hatte meine Sporttasche gepackt
und geplant, bis 16 Uhr zu arbeiten.
Ich wollte dann Feierabend machen
und mein Leben leben.
Tatsächlich war ich von 8 Uhr
bis Freitagabend um 20 Uhr
im Spital.
Ich blieb ganze 36 Std. im Dienst.
Es war der Beginn eines Albtraums.
Denn an jenem Tag haben wir
den ersten COVID-19-Fall in Europa
ohne eine direkte Verbindung
zu China diagnostiziert.
Mattia Maestri
ist 38 Jahre alt und sportlich.
An jenem Tag kommt er
mit einer leichten Lungenentzündung
ins Spital von Codogno.
Innert weniger Stunden verschlechtert
sich sein Zustand so sehr,
dass er in das besser ausgerüstete
Spital von Lodi verlegt wird.
Ich rufe den Radiologen und sage:
"Schau dir das verheerende CT
dieses Mannes an."
Dann gehe ich zum Patienten
und bin überrascht,
dass er
keine grösseren Beschwerden hat.
Er sagte,
das Atmen falle ihm etwas schwer,
aber keine grosse Sache.
Doch seine arteriellen Blutwerte
waren dramatisch.
(Mann) Am 21. Februar
brach ich nach Australien auf.
Ich war
zu einem Kongress eingeladen.
Bereits am Morgen des 22.
wurde ich von Nachrichten
über den Patienten in Codogno
und über Erkrankte in Schiavonia
überflutet.
Wie kann ich es beschreiben?
Ich wollte etwas tun, aber ich war
weit weg und noch immer unterwegs.
Ich tauschte gleich
nach meiner Ankunft das Ticket um
und kehrte am nächsten Tag zurück.
Ich wollte mit eigenen Augen sehen,
was da los war.
"Es ist wie eine Flutwelle."
"Patienten in der Notaufnahme.
Infektionskrankheiten."
"Alles Patienten und Mitarbeitende.
Schiavonia, Dolo, Mirano, Venedig."
Die reinste Katastrophe.
Meine erste Reaktion:
"Es sind zu viele Fälle.
Wir stehen vor einer Epidemie."
Codogno wird abgeriegelt.
(Mann) Le premier cas de Coronavirus
avait été attesté en Italie.
(Mann) ... la mise en quarantaine
de onze localités.
(Mann) ... die von den Behörden
von der Aussenwelt derzeit
komplett abgeriegelt werden.
(Frau) ... negozi, bar e scuole
chiuse, così appare da ieri Codogno.
(Frau, italienisch)
Ich erinnere mich,
dass es einen Fall in Lodi gab,
also bei uns in der Nähe.
Ein Mann habe sich angeblich
mit dem Coronavirus infiziert.
Solange es in China ist
und von China gesprochen wird,
schenkt man dem Ganzen
wenig Beachtung.
Wenn man dann hört,
dass es in der Nähe aufgetreten ist,
etwas Neues ist und keiner weiss,
wie man es heilen kann ...
Dieser Mann
war dann lange intubiert,
es war nicht einfach für ihn.
Natürlich gibt einem das zu denken.
Ich war in Sorge.
Ich bin immungeschwächt, da ich
seit 20 Jahren eine Krankheit habe,
die mit Immunsuppressiva
behandelt wird.
Ich sagte:
"Mir kann das nicht passieren."
"Mir doch nicht."
Ich habe auf nichts verzichtet,
es wusste ja keiner was.
In diesen Tagen ging ich zu
einem Hockeyspiel, ins Restaurant,
ins Café, ins Einkaufszentrum,
und ich habe weiter gearbeitet.
Ich fuhr in öffentlichen
Verkehrsmitteln zur Arbeit.
Die Züge kamen auch aus Italien.
Am Sonntagnachmittag schaute ich mir
in Bellinzona den Fasnachtsumzug an.
* Ungute Liegeklänge,
immer schnelleres Rattern *
(Daniel Koch) Ja, meine Damen
und Herren, im Grunde genommen
haben wir den ersten Fall
natürlich erwartet.
Jetzt ist er eingetroffen.
Jetzt wird genau das gemacht,
was wir auch vorbereitet haben,
was der Kanton Tessin
vorbereitet hat.
Il paziente, un settantenne,
vive in Ticino.
(Frau) La Suisse s'y préparait,
aujourd'hui à 16 heures ...
(Mann, italienisch) Ich erinnere
mich an dieses sehr hohe Fieber.
Es sank mit Antipyretika,
stieg aber gleich wieder.
Das Röntgen ergab
eine bilaterale Lungenentzündung.
Ich wurde sofort ins Spital
eingeliefert, in Isolation.
Der erste offiziell Infizierte
in der Schweiz
war nach ein paar Tagen geheilt.
Heute nimmt er
an einer Antikörperstudie teil.
Fast ein Jahr später fürchtet er
immer noch, als derjenige zu gelten,
der das Virus
ins Land eingeschleppt hat.
Ich merke, die Leute haben Angst.
Sie wissen nicht genau,
wie die Dynamik ist,
die Übertragung verläuft,
und was es heisst, immun zu sein.
Es scheint immer noch
der Eindruck zu bestehen,
man sei Virusträger.
Am 25. Februar
ist Bundesrat Alain Berset
für ein Treffen der europäischen
Gesundheitsminister in Rom.
Italien scheint
bereits in Schwierigkeiten.
Während des Treffens
erfährt der Schweizer Minister
vom ersten Fall im Tessin.
Damals wird die Inkubationszeit
des Virus auf 14 Tage geschätzt.
Ihm wird klar,
dass die Schweiz im Verzug ist.
Das Virus ist
seit mindestens zwei Wochen im Land.
Zur gleichen Zeit
treffen sich die kantonalen
Gesundheitsminister in Bern.
Das Tessin schlägt Alarm.
Doch für viele
ist das Virus noch weit weg.
(Mann, italienisch)
Ich kann Ihnen sagen,
dass man uns
vom 25./26. Februar an auslachte,
als ich
mit dem Bundesrat in Kontakt war,
als wir um Grenzkontrollen baten,
um dringende Massnahmen.
(Italienisch) Nicht-COVID-Patienten
kommen hierhin,
COVID-Patienten in den Warteraum.
Dort haben wir
vier COVID-Plätze eingerichtet.
(Italienisch)
Wir haben genug Inhalationsmaterial.
Wir haben genug
für die Sauerstoffversorgung.
Wir sind bereit.
* Hallende
Nachrichtenzusammenschnitte *
(Mann) Seit vergangener Woche
werden hier im Spital La Carità
in Locarno ...
In vier Tagen entstanden zwei
neue Abteilungen. Das sagt alles.
* Stimmengewirr *
(Mann) Es sind nun sieben Patienten
in der Chirurgie C.
Wir beginnen jetzt,
auch den vierten Stock zu belegen.
Am Freitag, den 6. März,
fühlte ich mich müde.
Es fühlte sich
wie leichtes Fieber an.
Als ich abends nach Hause kam,
hatte ich erhöhte Temperatur.
Wegen meiner Krankheit
habe ich sofort den Arzt angerufen.
Am Samstag
ging ich zum medizinischen Zentrum.
Ich wurde untersucht und geröntgt.
Meine Lungen waren einwandfrei.
Es wurden zwei Abstriche gemacht.
Einer für die üblichen Viren
und dann ein Corona-Test.
Ich hatte natürlich Panik.
Ich war sehr beunruhigt.
Am Samstagabend wurde ich angerufen.
Der Abstrich für die üblichen Viren
wie eine gewöhnliche Grippe,
Bakterien oder eine normale
Lungenentzündung war negativ.
Das Ergebnis des Corona-Tests
stand noch aus.
Das Wochenende war ein Albtraum.
* Ruhige sphärische Klänge *
Ich rief auch ständig meinen Partner
an und sagte:
"Heute gab es so und so viele
positive Personen,
heute gab es weitere Personen."
Denn es war von 50-60 Fällen
im Kanton Tessin die Rede.
Wir arbeiten in Schichten
von 12 Std. und 45 Min.
Normalerweise
höchstens drei bis vier Tage.
Aber jetzt sind wir immer da.
Wenn man gebraucht wird, ist man da.
Am Montag um 13 Uhr kam der Anruf:
"Elena, du bist positiv."
Ausser Fieber
hatte ich keine Symptome.
(Mann, französisch)
So, letzter Tag der Quarantäne.
Ich bin 26, habe noch nie geraucht,
trinke nur selten
und habe keine Krankheiten.
Es hat eigentlich
ganz unspektakulär angefangen.
An einem Wochenende
fühlte ich mich auf einmal unwohl.
Es ging mir nicht gut,
mir war heiss.
(Frau) Je vous passe
le laboratoire de microbiologie.
Am Mittwoch
wurde es auf einmal schlimmer.
Da war ich total erledigt,
konnte nicht mehr aufstehen.
Weil ich ein Praktikum
im Spitalumfeld machte,
empfahl man mir einen Test.
(Frau) On va vous appuyer
sur le thorax.
On va essayer de faire sortir
les sécrétions sur le poumon.
D'accord?
On vous appuye sur le ventre.
(Französisch) Heute Morgen
haben wir 35 COVID-Patienten,
davon 32 intubierte.
Ich habe gesehen,
dass die Station 12 voll ist.
Der nächste Schritt ist
die Notfallstation C mit 13 Betten.
Sobald Räume frei werden,
können wir sie beziehen.
Wir haben die Beatmungsgeräte,
alles Nötige.
Alles in einem Tag? - So schnell
wie möglich. In einem Tag.
(Mann) On s'attendait un jour
ou l'autre à cette annonce:
le coronavirus a fait
une première victime en Suisse.
(Frau) ... Svizzera legato
alla coronavirus è dunque vodese.
(Frau) ... dass es
auch in der Schweiz
den ersten Todesfall
wegen des Coronavirus gibt.
Gestorben ist heute eine
74-jährige Frau im Kanton Waadt.
Am Donnerstag fiel mir
ab der Mittagszeit alles schwer.
In der Nacht
von Donnerstag auf Freitag
rief ich dann um 3 Uhr
den Krankenwagen.
Ich schaffte es kaum ins Bad.
Ich hatte Atemnot.
Das Ergebnis kam am Donnerstag
und dann ...
Entschuldigung.
Es kam am Donnerstagnachmittag.
Ich war COVID-positiv.
Ich musste in Quarantäne
in meinem Zimmer, totale Isolation.
Meine Mitbewohner durften sich
im Rest der Wohnung frei bewegen,
aber nur einzeln.
Sie brachten mir Essen und Trinken.
Wir nahmen es ziemlich ernst.
Ich konnte
nicht mal mehr nach unten laufen.
Sie haben mich
mit einem Stuhl getragen.
Ich hatte keine Kraft.
Meine Mama kam herbeigeeilt.
Ich sah sie vor dem Haus,
aber wir konnten uns
nicht mal ... grüssen.
(Simonetta Sommaruga)
La situation est difficile,
mais nous avons les moyens
et nous sommes en mesure
d'y faire face
sur le plan medical et financier.
(Mann)
Dalla mezzanotte di questa sera
è decretato
lo stato di necessità ...
Es ist Freitag, der 13. März.
Die Schweizer Regierung
kündigt erste Schliessungen an.
Das Tessin sperrt zudem
einige Grenzübergänge zu Italien.
(Frau) La COVID-19 si espande
rapidamente in Svizzera
e fa altre due vittime
proprio in Ticino,
dove nelle ultime 24 ore
si è registrata
un impennata di casi positivi.
(Italienisch)
Wenn wir so weitermachen,
sind unsere Kapazitäten
in drei Tagen ausgeschöpft.
(Mann, italienisch)
Das sage ich schon die ganze Zeit.
Verzögern wir den Peak oder nicht?
Darum geht es.
(Mann) Ma questo grafico è di oggi?
Die Zahl der neuen Fälle
ist Tag für Tag angestiegen.
Ab dem zwölften Tag
ist sie höher als erwartet.
Jeden Tag sind es mehr neue Fälle.
Das Worst-Case-Szenario
ist bereits überschritten.
Wenn du das aus China hörst,
denkst du:
"Ich kann das besser,
bei mir stirbt keiner."
Stattdessen müssen wir erkennen,
dass die Chinesen
es genauso gut können wie wir,
dass wir genauso machtlos sind.
Jetzt sterben also Menschen.
* Nervöses Pochen, Liegeklänge *
(Christian de Mestral) Am Samstag
konnte ich nicht mehr liegen.
Ich hustete 1/2-1 Std. am Stück,
den ganzen Vormittag.
In der Notfallstation ...
Ich wurde geröntgt.
Man sagte mir,
es sei eine Lungenentzündung.
Ich wurde auf die Station gebracht.
Da stieg das Fieber so richtig.
Es ging über 38, 39 °C.
Mein Atem wurde schneller.
In der Nacht, nachdem ich vielleicht
1/2 Std. auf der Station war,
teilte man mir mit, ich müsse
auf die Überwachungsstation.
Die Krankenschwester sagte: "Die
Sättigung ist nicht ausreichend."
"Sie haben
nicht genug Sauerstoff im Blut."
Dann bekam ich Sauerstoff,
die ganze Zeit.
* Bedrückende Klänge *
(Elena Merlini)
Ich wurde nach Locarno gebracht.
Ich bin auf der Intensivstation
und hänge am Sauerstoffgerät.
Gestern erhielt ich
eine experimentelle Behandlung,
die in den nächsten 24-48 Std.
anschlagen
und die Lungenentzündung
etwas eindämmen sollte.
(Mit erstickter Stimme)
Ich hoffe, ich schaffe es.
Es ist schrecklich.
(Alain Berset) Heute Nachmittag
hat der Bundesrat entschieden,
die ausserordentliche Lage
gemäss Art. 7 des Epidemiengesetzes
anzuordnen.
* Unheilvolle Klänge *
Montag 16. März:
In der Schweiz beginnt der Lockdown.
Mit der ausserordentlichen Lage
geht die Entscheidungsbefugnis
von den Kantonen auf den Bund über.
Geschäfte, Restaurants,
Cafés und Freizeiteinrichtungen
müssen für einen Monat schliessen.
Die Regierung
mobilisiert 8'000 Soldaten.
Es kommt zu Hamsterkäufen.
Innerhalb weniger Wochen
wird ein ganzer Kontinent
und dann der ganze Planet
in die Knie gezwungen.
(Italienisch) Ich hatte
einen jungen, gesunden Patienten
mit einer viralen Lungenentzündung,
die sich innerhalb weniger Stunden
dramatisch verschlechterte.
Ich konnte es mir nicht erklären.
Man hatte ihn gefragt,
ob er kürzlich in China gewesen sei,
was aber nicht der Fall war.
Daher bestand zu dem Zeitpunkt
keine Notwendigkeit,
einen Corona-Test zu machen.
Gemäss den Leitlinien des Spitals
darf Ärztin Malara
keinen Corona-Test durchführen.
Sie macht es trotzdem.
Es erschien mir nicht richtig,
diese Hypothese
von vornherein auszuschliessen.
Für mich schien die Möglichkeit
einer Corona-Infektion
durchaus plausibel.
Der Test ist positiv.
Patient Mattia Maestri
liegt fast drei Wochen im Koma
und wird von einer Maschine
am Leben erhalten.
Er wacht gerade rechtzeitig auf,
um die Geburt seiner Tochter
mitzuerleben.
Sein Vater, der ebenfalls infiziert
wurde, hat es nicht geschafft.
Es war,
als ob ein Schalter umgelegt wurde.
Von diesem Moment an
kamen viele, sehr viele.
Wir hielten uns natürlich
nicht mehr an die Leitlinien,
das war hinfällig.
Wenn jemand mit akuter Atemnot
in die Notaufnahme kam,
stand für uns die Diagnose fest -
nach Röntgen des Brustkorbs,
aber ohne CT,
dazu waren es einfach zu viele.
Und wir lagen nicht falsch.
(Italienisch)
Auf diesem Parkplatz machten wir ...
Also, hierhin kamen die Leute.
Die Schlange
ging später bis dorthin.
Hier war der Eingang. Dort wurden
sie nach ihrem Ausweis gefragt.
Man stellte sich hier
in die Schlange.
Das Pflegepersonal verteilte sie
dann, je nachdem, wo sie hinmussten.
Wir hatten mind. 20 Ärzte,
vielleicht auch mehr,
Pflege- und anderes Personal.
Hier arbeiteten 60 Personen.
Wie lange dauerte es,
um alle zu testen?
Drei Tage.
1'000 Personen pro Tag.
Wenige Stunden nach dem ersten Fall
in Codogno wird das Virus
auch in der kleinen, ländlichen
Gemeinde Vo im Veneto entdeckt.
Innerhalb weniger Stunden
verhängt die Regierung in Rom
eine Komplettabriegelung
für die rund 3'000 Einwohner.
Auf Drängen
des Mikrobiologen Andrea Crisanti
beschliessen die lokalen Behörden
die Durchführung eines in Europa
bis dahin einzigartigen Experiments:
Die gesamte Bevölkerung
wird dreimal getestet.
Vo wird zu einem Analyselabor,
das danach weltweit
als Modell dienen wird.
(Mann, italienisch) In Vo führten
wir fast eine zweite Erhebung durch.
Diese gab Aufschluss
über eine Reihe wichtiger Dinge,
die uns dann helfen, die Dynamik
der Epidemie zu verstehen.
Nämlich, dass der Anteil
der asymptomatischen Fälle
extrem hoch ist: rund 40 %.
Dass asymptomatische Personen
das Virus übertragen können.
Dass der Anteil der positiv
Getesteten sehr hoch war: 3 %.
Wir zeigten auch,
dass Kinder gegenüber dem Virus
deutlich resistenter sind.
Die Zahl der Ansteckungen
ist etwa zehnmal geringer.
Und wichtig: Wir zeigten,
dass nach Isolierung aller positiven
Personen mit und ohne Symptome,
während der Rest der Bevölkerung
sich frei bewegen konnte,
die Übertragung
komplett eingedämmt wurde.
Was bedeutet das?
Wenn man die Tests korrekt einsetzt,
braucht es keinen Lockdown.
Andrea Crisanti ist Professor
am Imperial College London
und an der Universität Padua.
Seine Studie,
die später in der Fachzeitschrift
"Nature" veröffentlicht wird,
ist eine erste wichtige Warnung:
Achtung, fast die Hälfte der COVID-
19-Positiven ist symptomfrei.
Diese asymptomatischen Personen
übertragen das Virus
aber sehr effizient.
Wissen Sie, was das Problem ist?
Als wir die Daten aus Vo ver-
öffentlichten, glaubte uns niemand.
Die WHO ...
Nun, sie hat alles falsch gemacht,
was man falsch machen konnte.
U.a. sagte sie, es gebe
keine asymptomatischen Personen,
und wenn doch,
dass die keine Überträger seien.
Also eine ganze Reihe von Angaben,
die auf nichts beruhten.
Denn die WHO
hatte eine Richtlinie ausgegeben,
dass nur Patienten
mit respiratorischen Symptomen,
die Kontakt zu Erkrankten hatten,
getestet werden sollten.
Das Problem war,
dass die Gesundheitsbehörden an
diesen WHO-Empfehlungen festhielten.
(Frau, englisch) Fälle,
in denen eine asymptomatische Person
das Virus überträgt,
scheinen immer noch selten.
Wir wollen deshalb v.a. die
symptomatischen Fälle nachverfolgen.
Noch im Juni 2020
behauptet die WHO in Genf,
es gebe keine eindeutigen Beweise
für einen Zusammenhang zwischen
asymptomatischen Fällen und COVID-19.
Damit nicht genug.
Auch China hatte, obwohl es wusste,
dass seit Wochen
eine neue Infektionskrankheit
im Land grassierte,
erst am 20. Januar bestätigt,
dass das Virus
von Mensch zu Mensch übertragen wird.
Am Vortag hatte die WHO
bei ihrem Besuch in Peking
die Reaktion Chinas auf
den neuen Gesundheitsnotstand gelobt.
(Englisch) Sie haben strenge
Gesundheitsmassnahmen ergriffen.
Das ist sehr, sehr wichtig.
Und wir sind stolz.
Durch die verspätete Offenlegung,
möglicherweise auch Vertuschung,
der Daten zum Coronavirus,
das monatelange hartnäckige Leugnen
seitens der WHO
und das Chaos bei der Kommunikation
konnte sich das Virus
unkontrolliert verbreiten.
Vo war eine verpasste Gelegenheit,
um die Welt vor asymptomatischen
Fällen zu warnen.
Dies umso mehr, als
bereits in der zweiten Januarhälfte
eine Ärztin aus Deutschland
Alarm schlug:
Camilla Rothe
vom Tropeninstitut München.
(Frau) Am 27. Januar
klingelte bei uns im
Tropeninstitut München das Telefon.
Eine Autozulieferfirma war dran.
Sie fragten, ob wir auf dieses
neue Coronavirus testen können.
Die deutsche Webasto-Gruppe ist einer
der grössten Automobilzulieferer
und hat rund zehn Fertigungsstätten
in China,
darunter eine grosse in Wuhan.
Im Führungsteam
macht sich Sorge breit:
Einer der Angestellten
zeigt merkwürdige Symptome,
nachdem er eine chinesische
Mitarbeiterin getroffen hatte,
die für drei Tage
zu Besuch in München war.
Wir luden den Herrn ein
zu uns in die Ambulanz,
in genau diesen Raum.
Als er kam, hatte er schon
keine nennenswerten Symptome mehr,
das lag bereits zurück.
Er hatte also v.a. Sorge.
Ich machte den Abstrich.
Gegen Abend wurde ich
vom Labor der Bundeswehr angerufen,
das uns bestätigte,
dass dieser Abstrich positiv sei.
Das war der erste deutsche Fall
von COVID-19.
Camilla Rothe
identifizierte acht Fälle,
die auf Kontakte
mit der chinesischen Mitarbeiterin
zurückgeführt werden konnten.
Die Frau selber jedoch wies
keinerlei Krankheitssymptome auf.
Da gingen bei mir
relativ bald die Alarmglocken an.
Wenn wir uns
in den Januar zurückversetzen -
ich habe mir den Zeitstrahl
noch mal angesehen -,
da muss man sich überlegen:
Am 20. Januar, also eine Woche,
bevor wir den ersten Fall sahen,
gab die WHO erst bekannt,
dass eine
Mensch-zu-Mensch-Transmission,
eine Übertragung von Mensch zu
Mensch, wahrscheinlich stattfindet.
Auf diesem Niveau waren wir.
Sie erkennt
die Bedeutung der Entdeckung
und reicht einen Artikel beim "New
England Journal of Medecine" ein.
Wegen der globalen Tragweite
wird er sofort veröffentlicht.
Auch asymptomatische Personen
übertragen das Virus.
Wir kämpften von da an noch
mehrere Monate gegen Protokolle.
Ich leite diese klinische Ambulanz
und sagte:
"Wir setzen uns darüber hinweg
und machen es,
wie wir es mit unserer Erfahrung
für richtig erachten,
und dafür stehe ich gerade."
Dank der Entschlossenheit
von Annalisa Malara und Camilla Rothe
werden neue Aspekte des Virus
bekannt:
Sie haben getestet,
egal, ob eine Verbindung zu China
bestand oder nicht.
Die Ergebnisse
hätten Europa alarmieren müssen:
Vorsicht beim Kontakt mit China.
Ein Land aber reagiert sofort:
Taiwan.
(Mann, englisch)
Das war am 31. Dezember,
dem letzten Tag des Jahres.
Da war dieser Post über ein
unerklärliches gehäuftes Auftreten
von Lungenentzündungen in Wuhan,
China.
Zu jener Zeit war Lo Yi-Chun
Sprecher für das taiwanesische
Gesundheitsministerium.
In dieser Nacht fielen ihm
in der Kommunikation der chinesischen
Kollegen einige Warnsignale auf.
Da gab es drei wichtige Botschaften.
Die erste
war eine offizielle Meldung
der Gesundheitsbehörde in Wuhan
an die Spitäler:
"Es gibt einen Ausbruch
von Lungenentzündungen
unter Spitalpatienten."
"Passen Sie auf, dass Sie
das Gesundheitspersonal schützen."
Die zweite Botschaft war,
dass Ärzte einander rieten:
"Schaut,
dass ihr diese Patienten isoliert."
Die dritte Botschaft
waren Chats unter Ärzten:
"In meinem Spital
habe ich schon so viele Fälle
der Wuhan-Lungenentzündung."
Sie dachten,
dass diese mit Wuhan und dem
Meeresfrüchtemarkt zusammenhingen,
und erste Labortests
wiesen auf SARS hin.
Taiwan schlägt bei der WHO
via E-Mail Alarm
und fordert mehr Informationen
über das Geschehen in China.
Die Antwort aus Genf
ist wenig hilfreich.
Die WHO sagte:
"Wir stehen in Kontakt mit Peking."
Sie antworteten nicht
auf unsere Fragen, meinten nur:
"Danke, wir haben
Ihre Meldung erhalten", das war's.
Sieht so aus, als ob sie einfach
alles glaubten, was Peking sagte.
Offenbar hat das,
was Taiwan alarmiert hat,
die WHO nicht beunruhigt.
Taiwan will nicht abwarten.
Noch an diesem 31. Dezember
beschliesst das Land
erste Massnahmen.
Darunter die systematische Kontrolle
aller Flugreisenden aus Wuhan
ab dem 1. Januar 2020
und später aus ganz China.
Dank der schnellen Reaktion
verzeichnete die Insel
mit 25 Mio. Einwohnern -
Stand ein Jahr nach Ausbruch -
knapp über 900 COVID-Fälle
und nur neun Tote.
15 Tage nach der Warnung Taiwans
und noch vor Entdeckung
der ersten Fälle in München
landet in Rom ein Flugzeug
mit einer 30-köpfigen Reisegruppe,
ausgerechnet aus Wuhan.
Von Rom reist die Gruppe
zehn Tage lang durch Europa
und die Schweiz bis nach Paris -
ohne Gesundheitskontrolle.
Das europäische Alarmsystem
schlägt an,
als fünf Gruppenmitglieder
nach Ankunft in Paris
positiv getestet werden.
Zeitnah flackert die Meldung
auch über die Computerbildschirme
im Bundesamt für Gesundheit in Bern.
(Mann)
Wir erhielten Mitte Januar,
im Rahmen eines Frühwarnsystems,
das wir mit der WHO haben,
per E-Mail die Information,
dass da eine Reisegruppe
unterwegs war,
die u.a. auch
durch die Schweiz reiste.
Die Schweiz reagiert sofort.
Es ist Mitte Januar.
Nur eineinhalb Monate später
gibt es den ersten
offiziellen COVID-Fall im Land.
Für Mark Witschi, der die Recherchen
koordiniert, ist ausschlaggebend,
so schnell wie möglich
die Bewegungen und Kontakte
der Gruppe zu kennen.
Gemäss den Informationen, die wir
von dieser Reiseleiterin erhielten,
fuhren sie durch den Kanton Tessin
und machten dort keine Pausen.
Ob sie an einer Raststätte
einen WC-Halt machten,
das entzieht sich
aber meiner Kenntnisse.
Darüber wurden wir nicht informiert.
Wir hörten:
Die Gruppe war in Interlaken.
"Wo denn in Interlaken?"
"Sie bewegten sich 2 Std. frei."
Wir wussten nicht: Waren die
unter vielen anderen Touristen?
Mit engem Kontakt? Ungeschützt?
Das wusste man damals noch nicht.
Waren sie in Einkaufszentren,
in Läden, in Restaurants?
Kanton Luzern, Zug, Bern.
Auch mit dem Zug
waren die Chinesen unterwegs.
Ihre nahen Kontakte
werden aufgespürt.
Die internationale Nachforschung
ergibt, dass eine Frau aus der Gruppe
bereits auf dem Flug von China
nach Italien infiziert war.
Zum Ende der Reise
sind es fünf Infizierte.
Man wusste:
In Wuhan läuft dieser Ausbruch.
Alles, was wir heute wissen,
wusste man damals noch nicht.
Ich war schon etwas nervös -
im Gedanken,
dass das der erste Übertragungsfall
innerhalb der Schweiz sein könnte,
und dass man von Anfang an
ganz nah dran gewesen wäre.
Zur Erinnerung: Erst am 20. Januar
gesteht Peking die Mensch-zu-Mensch-
Übertragung offiziell ein.
Währenddessen
übernachtet die Reisegruppe aus Wuhan
in einem Hotel in Sursee/LU.
Drei Tage später, am 23.,
wird Wuhan abgeriegelt
und von der Welt isoliert.
Am 29. Januar lobt Tedros
Ghebreyesus, Generaldirektor der WHO,
in Peking
die Notfallmassnahmen Chinas.
Einen Tag später ruft die WHO
den internationalen
Gesundheitsnotstand aus,
rät jedoch von Beschränkungen
gegenüber China ab.
(Englisch) Die WHO empfiehlt
keine Reise-
oder Handelsbeschränkungen
oder andere Massnahmen gegen China.
Sie ist sogar dagegen.
Und so gibt es bis Mitte März
keine Beschränkungen
auf europäischen Flughäfen.
In Genf stehen die Skifahrer
vor den Gates dicht an dicht.
Der Punkt, wo man heute sagt,
Europa - nicht nur die Schweiz -
habe nicht reagiert,
war die ganze Einschränkung
mit den Reisen.
Dass man nicht sagte:
"Man darf oder soll
nicht mehr nach China reisen."
Heute würde man das sehr
wahrscheinlich viel früher sagen.
Man würde man sagen:
"Hey, das ist ein Problem."
Da kann man sagen ...
Da hat nicht die Schweiz,
sondern die Welt versagt.
Man hat die Ausbreitung
ausserhalb von China
völlig unterschätzt.
Daniel Koch,
Mr Corona der Schweiz bis zu
seiner Pensionierung Ende Mai 2020,
erhielt Anerkennung für sein ruhiges
Agieren in heiklen Momenten.
Die grosse Überraschung für Europa
kam,
als man in Italien
plötzlich Todesfälle sah.
Von Anfang an war klar:
"Wenn wir Todesfälle sehen,
ist es schon zu spät."
"Dann haben sich schon
viel mehr angesteckt."
Es war auch klar:
Es wird nicht möglich sein,
die Infektionsketten
noch einzeln nachzuvollziehen.
(Englisch) Wir sind deshalb
zum Schluss gekommen,
dass COVID-19
als Pandemie eingestuft werden kann.
Einige chinesische Ärzte
meldeten Ende Dezember erste Fälle.
Taiwan bemerkte das
und warnte die WHO.
Camilla Rothe aus München
und der Mikrobiologe Crisanti
publizierten ihre Entdeckungen
Anfang des Jahres
in wissenschaftlichen Zeitschriften.
Währenddessen vergingen die Wochen
und das Virus
verbreitete sich über den Globus.
Die WHO aber rief
erst am 11. März die Pandemie aus.
* Tiefe, wabernde Klänge *
(Mann) Am Anfang
herrschte grosse Unsicherheit.
Man wusste nicht,
wann es wirklich kam.
Kann das überhaupt sein?
Was passiert mit diesem Virus?
Wir sagten einander:
"Siehst du, du wurdest doch krank."
Als wir das im März hörten.
"Hätte ja Corona sein können."
Aber das waren Sprüche
untereinander.
(Mann) Erst als das Ganze
aufgerollt wurde,
hörte man
von Verschwörungstheorien,
dass es Amerikaner
nach Amerika zurückbrachten,
und dass sich ein Italiener
ganz schlecht gefühlt habe.
Da kam man ins Denken.
Aber die ersten zwei, drei Monate,
nachdem wir von Wuhan zurück waren,
war das noch kein Thema.
Von 18.-27. Oktober 2019
reisten rund 10'000 Sportler
aus aller Welt
zu den Militärweltspielen in Wuhan.
Teams wie Frankreich, Schweden,
Luxemburg und Italien meldeten,
einige Teilnehmer hätten während
und nach den Wettkämpfen Fieber,
Lungenentzündungen
und allgemeine Grippesymptome gehabt.
(Mann, italienisch) Es schien,
als hätten viele von uns die Grippe.
Fast alle
hatten diesen starken Husten.
Mich hatte es sehr schlimm erwischt.
50-60 %, mind. 50 % der Leute,
die in meiner Nähe gewesen waren,
wurden krank.
Wir hatten alle
ungefähr dieselben Symptome.
Als dann Monate später
das Thema Coronavirus aufkam,
vermuteten wir,
dass es das gewesen war.
Einige aus dem Schweizer Team
der Orientierungsläufer
werden während und nach
den Wettkämpfen ebenfalls krank.
Belege für eine Coronavirus-Infektion
gibt es aber nicht.
Wir finden heraus,
dass ein Analyselabor in Bern
Blutproben der zehn Teammitglieder
für einen Routinetest
Anfang März 2020 aufbewahrt.
Wir erhalten Einblick.
Wenn es Antikörper gab,
könnten sich die Schweizer Sportler
in Wuhan
mit COVID-19 angesteckt haben.
Aber es ist viel Zeit vergangen.
Nur noch zwei Blutproben
sind im Kühlraum,
und zwar die beiden
der Medaillengewinner von Wuhan,
Matthias Kyburz und Florian Howald.
(Mann)
Ich schwitzte sehr in der Nacht,
und am Tag danach
hatte ich am Abend Fieber
und fühlte mich nicht wohl,
war müde.
Aber am Tag danach
konnte ich den Wettkampf laufen.
So schlimm
kann es daher nicht gewesen sein.
Es war keine klassische Grippe,
die mich meine Form gekostet hätte,
sonst hätte ich am Tag danach
keine solche Leistung zeigen können.
Das Resultat war gut?
Am Tag danach
gewannen wir die Staffel.
Ich lief die Schlussstrecke
und konnte fürs Team
die Goldmedaille sichern.
Von daher war alles gut, ja.
Matthias Kyburz und Florian Howald
zählen zur internationalen Elite
im Orientierungslauf.
Als sie mit drei Goldmedaillen aus
Wuhan zurückkehren, ahnen sie nicht,
was wenig später in der chinesischen
Metropole passieren wird -
ausgerechnet in den Spitälern,
in denen auch ein Teamkollege
von ihnen behandelt wurde.
(Florian Howald) Einer hatte sich
beim letzten Wettkampf verletzt.
So, wie ich es in Erinnerung habe,
wurde er zu Hause krank.
Aber eben vielleicht noch geschwächt
durch die Verletzung,
von der Flugreise und so.
Er ist derjenige,
der noch am ehesten Kontakt hatte,
weil er dort ins Spital musste.
(Matthias Kyburz)
Ich wusste gar nicht,
dass diese Blutproben
aufbewahrt wurden.
Es war ein einfacher Blutabstrich
zur Eisenkontrollle,
wie als Sportler üblich.
Ich wusste gar nicht,
dass sie noch zur Verfügung standen.
Von diesem Projekt
erfuhr ich erst durch euch.
Ich hatte nicht daran gedacht,
weil ich diese Möglichkeit
gar nicht wahrgenommen hatte.
* Einzelne,
beklemmende Klavierakkorde *
Ich erinnere mich, dass gegen Mittag
die Zimmertür aufging
und eine Maschine
hereingeschoben wurde.
Dahinter fünf oder sechs Personen:
Anästhesisten, Ärzte, Pfleger.
Sie sagten mir:
"Elena, wir müssen Sie intubieren."
Das war wie ein Schlag für mich.
In dem Moment sah ich ...
begriff ich es nicht.
Ich war wie vom Blitz getroffen.
Ich verstand nicht, warum.
Ich hatte nicht gedacht,
dass ich so schwer erkrankt war.
* Einzelne,
beklemmende Klavierakkorde *
Ich rief meine Mutter an,
die erste Person, und sagte:
"Sie müssen mich intubieren."
Ich hatte es selbst
erst 30 Min. zuvor erfahren
und wusste sonst nichts.
Dann gab ich ihr den Anästhesisten.
Ich konnte
nicht einmal meinen Partner anrufen,
um ihm Bescheid zu sagen.
Dann weiss ich nichts mehr, bis ich
am 31. März wieder aufgewacht bin -
zwei Wochen später.
Da bin ich wieder.
In der Notfallstation
nach drei Tagen in Freiheit.
Wegen fürchterlicher Schmerzen
im Brustkorb rechts,
die auch die Atmung beeinträchtigen.
Ich kann nicht liegen,
nur aufrecht sitzen.
So geht es seit 24 Std.
Man hat mich hingelegt,
um einen Ultraschall zu machen,
um mal zu schauen.
Nicht einmal ganz flach.
Solche Schmerzen.
Zum Glück wirkt das Morphium.
Es tut weniger weh.
Aber ich habe trotzdem Angst,
dass der Schmerz wiederkommt ...
... dass es
noch nicht überstanden ist.
* Bedrückende, langsame Musik *
Das Labor in Bern,
das die Blutproben
der beiden Schweizer Sportler
aufbewahrt,
die im Oktober an den Wettkämpfen
in Wuhan teilgenommen haben,
erlaubt uns,
eine serologische Untersuchung
der Proben durchzuführen.
Es ist die einzige
und letzte Möglichkeit,
allfällige Spuren des Virus
im Blut der Sportler nachzuweisen.
Sie sagten, die Infektion
wäre im März geschehen?
Also im März die Blutprobe.
Die Blutprobe. Und die Erkrankung?
Oktober. Das ist die grosse Frage.
- Ach so, so lange schon.
Oh.
Ja. Schauen wir mal.
Aber das ist
eine relativ lange Zeit.
Und nach dem, was wir heute wissen,
kann man nicht garantieren,
dass wir jetzt etwas sehen,
selbst wenn das schon COVID war.
Mich würde es sehr erstaunen,
wenn der positiv wäre.
Das war im Oktober.
Man wusste ja noch nichts davon,
aber es existierte
wahrscheinlich schon.
Wir haben einzelne Patienten,
die sich in Abständen von Monaten
mehrfach testen liessen.
Man sieht dann: Am Anfang
war es noch recht deutlich,
beim zweiten Mal
sah man es noch knapp,
und beim dritten Mal
sah man schon nichts mehr -
nach drei bis vier Monaten.
* Bedrohliche Musik *
Ist es da?
- Ja.
Aber der ist negativ, gell?
- Genau.
Das hier ist Howald, Florian.
Er ist negativ.
Bei uns oben war er auch negativ.
- Das wurde mir gesagt.
Wir können
mit diesem Testsystem nicht zeigen,
dass Sie die Infektion hatten.
Das heisst aber nicht,
dass Sie sicher keine hatten.
Wir konnten es
einfach nicht beweisen.
* Pulsierende Musik *
(Florian Howald)
Eine lustige Geschichte ist,
dass wir mal noch einen richtigen
chinesischen Markt sehen wollten,
wo es vielleicht
auch etwas widerliche Tiere gibt.
Im Nachhinein
kann man vielleicht sagen,
dass wir zum Glück keinen fanden,
nur einen Gemüsemarkt.
(Matthias Kyburz) Eigentlich
habe ich das Resultat so erwartet.
Wenn das Resultat
positiv gewesen wäre,
dann wäre das schon
eine Weltsensation gewesen.
Dann hätte man beweisen können,
dass es schon im Oktober
angefangen hatte,
nicht erst ein, zwei Monate später.
Ich glaube,
das Thema hätte viral gehen
und die ganze Geschichte
nochmals neu aufrollen können.
Tatsächlich hat die Wissenschaft
inzwischen bewiesen,
dass das Virus in Wuhan
schon wenige Tage
nach der Durchreise der Teilnehmenden
der Militär-WM existierte.
Das bestätigen die phylogenetischen
Studien von Tanja Stadler,
Forscherin und Mitglied der wissen-
schaftlichen Taskforce der Schweiz.
Wir schauten uns zu Anfang
die Genomsequenzen
dieses SARS-CoV-2 Virus an.
Hier sehen wir
den Schweizer Transmissionsbaum.
Alle Punkte
repräsentieren Genomsequenzen
von positiv getesteten
Schweizer Personen -
also die Genomsequenz des Virus,
nicht des Menschen.
Wir sehen,
wie diese Viren verwandt sind.
Sie haben alle einen Ursprung.
Anhand von den Mutationen
und Veränderungen
kann man berechnen,
wann der Ausbruch war.
Da kommt man so auf Mitte,
Ende November in China, in Wuhan.
Dann hat
diese ganze Pandemie angefangen.
Mit der Mathematik
lässt sich der Zeitpunkt
der Virusausbreitung rekonstruieren.
Wasser aber
speichert Spuren aller Elemente,
die in der Umgebung vorhanden sind.
Diese Proben haben
seit Ende Februar entnommen
dank der grosszügigen Mithilfe
der Kläranlagenbetreiber im Tessin.
Dann haben wir zusätzlich
Lausanne und Zürich,
die wir rückblickend
analysieren können.
Die Forschungsanstalt
EAWAG Dübendorf
hat COVID am 29. Februar 2020
im Abwasser des Kantons Tessin
nachgewiesen -
vier Tage nach der Identifizierung
des vermeintlichen Patienten 0.
* Eindringliche Musik *
Hat man in Dübendorf daran gedacht,
noch weiter
in der Zeit zurückzugehen?
Vielleicht war das Virus
schon vor dem 25. Februar im Wasser?
Im Tessin hat keine Kläranlage
ältere Proben aufbewahrt.
Die oberste Gesundheitsbehörde in Rom
beschäftigt sich seit 25 Jahren
mit Umweltvirologie.
Schon fast 15 Jahre lang
wendet sie ihre Techniken
bei der Untersuchung von Wasser
aus städtischen Kläranlagen an.
Dorthin gelangt jedes Virus
über Kot und Urin der Bevölkerung.
Aus den entnommenen Proben lassen
sich genetische Sequenzen isolieren,
die in einem komplexen Verfahren
mit weltweiten Datenbanken
verglichen werden.
(Frau, italienisch) Dies ist die
Beschreibung des gefundenen Genoms,
das mit unserem identisch ist.
Das erste auf der Liste
ist das am nächsten verwandte.
Es besteht
eine Übereinstimmung von 100 %.
Oben sehen wir unsere Probe
und darunter die gesuchte Probe.
Sie sind vollkommen identisch.
Wir haben also eindeutig
SARS-CoV-2 identifiziert.
Am 24. Februar bestätigt sich
für das Team von Giuseppina La Rosa:
Das Virus
ist im italienischen Abwasser.
Über 2'500 Proben
lagern in den Gefrierschränken
des Instituts in Rom:
das Resultat
von fast 15 Jahren Arbeit,
konserviert bei -70 °C.
Zu diesem Zeitpunkt verwendeten wir
Proben aus unserer Datenbank,
um eine retrospektive Studie
durchzuführen.
So gingen wir in der Zeit immer
weiter zurück, um herauszufinden,
inwieweit das Virus bereits vor den
gemeldeten Fällen verbreitet war,
wie von vielen Wissenschaftlern
angenommen.
Wir konzentrierten uns
auf die Proben
der vorgehenden Monate
Oktober bis Februar,
insbesondere aus den drei Städten
Mailand, Turin und Bologna.
Sie liegen
nicht weit von Codogno entfernt,
wo wir die Person
identifiziert hatten,
die wir für den Patienten 0 hielten.
Tatsächlich fanden wir,
was wir erwartet hatten:
Positivität für das SARS-CoV-2-Genom
in Proben,
die wir im Dezember,
genauer gesagt am 18. Dezember,
in den Städten Mailand und Turin
entnommen hatten,
und in den Januarproben aus Bologna.
Das Virus
gab es also schon zwei Monate,
bevor der erste Fall gemeldet wurde.
D.h., das Virus
war bereits Mitte Dezember 2019
in Norditalien im Abwasser vorhanden.
Fünf internationale Experten
hatten die Entdeckung des Teams
um Giuseppina Rosa überprüft,
bevor sie in wissenschaftlichen
Zeitschriften veröffentlicht wurde.
Die Ergebnisse der Studie
regten weitere Wissenschaftler an,
ebenfalls ältere, bei Minusgraden
aufbewahrte Proben zu untersuchen.
Eine Untersuchung der Universität
Mailand konnte das Coronavirus
im Masernabstrich eines Kindes
von Ende November 2019 nachweisen.
Bei einer anderen Forschungsarbeit
wurde es sogar
in einer dermatologischen Biopsie
vom 10. November gefunden.
Europa hatte also schon drei Monate
mit dem Virus zusammengelebt,
ohne es zu bemerken.
Erst die Umweltvirologie
brachte es ans Licht.
Zu diesem Zeitpunkt
wusste man ja noch gar nicht,
wonach man suchen sollte.
Die genetische Sequenz des Virus
war noch nicht bekannt.
Am 10. Januar 2020 wurde diese
kostbare Information veröffentlicht.
Doch erst die Fälle Ende Februar
machten uns bewusst,
dass wir
kurz vor einer Pandemie standen.
Vielleicht
können wir neue Viren in Zukunft
dank der Umweltvirologie
schneller im Abwasser nachweisen
und daraus Schlüsse
über ihre Verbreitung ziehen.
Bei der nächsten Epidemie
könnte dies der Schlüssel für
ein besseres Krisenmanagement sein.
* Bedrückende Musik *
(Italienisch) Sie spricht nur
mit Lippenbewegungen,
kann sich aber verständlich machen.
- Aber sie ist wach?
Ja. Die Mutter habe ich
schon angerufen. Sie freut sich.
Haben wir die Nummer?
- Kommt!
Claudia, du musst
die Familie anrufen und sagen:
"Macht euch bereit
für einen WhatsApp-Anruf."
Das ist Teamarbeit.
Super! Hallo, Robi, wie geht's?
- Gut. Und selbst?
Gut, gut.
- Geht ihr zu ihr?
Ja, wir machen einen Videoanruf
bei der Familie.
Guten Abend! Hallo.
Wir gehen jetzt rein.
- Guten Abend.
Wir sind drei Pfleger
und gehen jetzt ins Zimmer, okay?
Ja.
- Okay. Los geht's.
Ich erinnere mich an den Moment,
als ich die Augen öffnete.
Es kam mir vor wie das Paradies,
ich weiss auch nicht.
In diesem Moment fragte ich mich:
"Elena, was ist passiert?"
Kaum 2 Sek. später:
"Elena, du lebst! Elena, du lebst!"
Elena, schauen Sie mal,
wen ich mitgebracht habe.
Elena, erkennen Sie sie?
(Tränenerstickt) Seit wann bist du
aus der Intensivstation raus?
Jetzt wird es dir von Tag zu Tag
besser gehen, du wirst sehen.
Du besiegst diese Bestie!
Komm, Elena, bitte.
Du schaffst das. Du schaffst das!
(Italienisch) Frau Fagetti,
ich bin Avena - die Palliativärztin,
die sich zusammen mit den Kollegen
der Abteilung
um Ihre Mutter kümmert.
Wir möchten Ihnen Gelegenheit geben,
sich zu verabschieden.
Hier, die Brille aufsetzen,
nochmals die Hände desinfizieren
und die Handschuhe anziehen.
* Klopfen *
Ciao, Mamma.
- Ciao, Mamma.
Ich kann nicht näher kommen, Mama.
Ich kann dich nicht umarmen.
Wie geht's dir, Mama?
Wir müssen Abstand halten.
Schickst du mir einen Kuss, Mama?
Sie war nicht so
für Umarmungen und Küsse.
Ich glaube, ich habe ein Foto
zu Hause, als ich klein war.
Wir waren am Meer
und sie hielt meine Hand.
Viele Grüsse von allen.
* Schniefen, Schluchzen *
* Einzelne,
beklemmende Klavierakkorde *
(Simonetta Sommaruga)
Meine Damen und Herren,
wir haben jetzt viele
unserer alten Freiheiten wieder.
Restaurants und Bars sind offen.
Mitte April kündigt die Regierung
Lockerungsmassnahmen an.
Dann kommt der Sommer mit einer
beruhigenden Entspannung der Lage.
Doch im Herbst
trifft uns eine zweite Welle,
die noch viel heftiger ist
als die erste.
Dieses Mal ist auch
die Deutschschweiz stark betroffen.
Die Zahlen und Statistiken, mit denen
wir tagtäglich überhäuft werden,
bieten wenig Sicherheit.
Eines ist jedoch unstrittig:
die Zahl der Toten.
2020 gab es bei der Sterblichkeit
zwei Höhepunkte -
im April und im November.
Schon in den Jahren 2015 und 2017
hatte es aufgrund von Grippeepidemien
ähnliche Zahlen gegeben.
Das Virus
trifft nicht alle gleich hart.
Unter den Opfern
sind in erster Linie ältere Menschen.
70 % der Verstorbenen
sind älter als 80 Jahre,
20 % zwischen 70 und 80.
2020 verzeichneten wir weltweit
fast 2 Mio. Todesfälle
infolge von COVID-19.
Beeindruckende Zahlen.
Wir dürfen jedoch nicht vergessen,
dass das Virus in dieser Zeit
nicht die einzige Todesursache ist.
Durchschnittlich
sterben jedes Jahr 9 Mio. Menschen
an den Folgen
von Umweltverschmutzung,
7 Mio. durch Rauchen
und 3 Mio. durch Alkoholkonsum.
Die täglichen Berichte
über Infizierte und Tote
überschatten andere
negative Auswirkungen der Pandemie:
die wirtschaftlichen,
sozialen und psychischen Folgen
des Coronavirus.
(Mann, italienisch) Zunächst wirken
sich Pandemien und Katastrophen
auf alle gleich aus.
Sie treffen die gesamte Bevölkerung,
ob arm oder reich.
Das Problem tritt erst später auf.
Wer über mehr Mittel verfügt,
kann sich veränderten
Lebensbedingungen besser anpassen,
kann z.B. von zu Hause aus arbeiten.
Dann erst
zeigen sich die Unterschiede.
Sandro Cattacin,
Leiter des Instituts für soziologi-
sche Forschung der Universität Genf,
hat gemeinsam
mit Kolleginnen und Kollegen
die Folgen der derzeitigen Krise
für die Gesellschaft untersucht.
COVID hat dafür gesorgt,
dass die Armut wieder zunimmt,
und dieser Trend wird sich
über mehrere Jahre fortsetzen.
Was sich nicht geändert hat:
Reichtum
und die Konzentration des Reichtums
bleiben in denselben Händen.
Die Zahl der Reichen
hat weltweit sogar zugenommen.
Die Gesellschaft
wird also in zwei Hälften geteilt.
Vor COVID geschah dies
mehr oder weniger unsichtbar,
doch nun stehen die Mittellosen
faktisch auf der Strasse
und lassen ein Bild entstehen,
das sich einbrennt:
Tausende Menschen,
die vor der Eishalle von Vernets
auf Nahrungsmittelpakete warten,
um zu überleben,
um etwas zu essen zu haben.
Ich würde sagen,
die Särge von Bergamo
und die Essenssäcke von Vernets
sind zu Symbolen
dieser ganzen Krise geworden,
die wir gerade erleben.
* Beklemmende Musik *
(Kind) Salut, Maman.
- Coucou.
Ça va, mes amours?
Faites attention de ne pas tomber.
Attention de pas tomber. Salut.
- Salut.
Die Geschäftsmiete
der letzten drei Monate,
die Wohnungsmiete,
die Krankenkassenprämien
für die Kinder und mich natürlich
und Strom:
etwas mehr als 8'000 Fr.
Ich wäre auch bereit,
auf mein Geschäft zu verzichten
und eine andere Arbeit anzunehmen -
sogar als Putzfrau, egal was.
Manche waren
schon vor der Pandemie arm,
andere sind es
in den letzten Monaten erst geworden.
Um ihre beiden Kinder zu versorgen
und ihr Coiffeurgeschäft
nicht aufgeben zu müssen,
war Nieves Varela gezwungen,
bei ihrer Bank
einen Kredit zu beantragen.
Ich musste trotzdem dieses viel
zitierte zinslose Darlehen annehmen,
um mich wenigstens
ein wenig über Wasser halten
und einige Rechnungen
zahlen zu können,
um nicht zu sehr im Verzug zu sein.
So stellt man es sich nicht vor.
Mit 42 an diesem Punkt zu sein,
Diese Grenze zu überschreiten
und zu sagen:
"Nun gehöre ich auch zu den Armen."
"Ich gehöre zu den Bedürftigen,
die nichts mehr haben."
Auf einem Konto hatte ich 1.15 Fr.
und auf dem anderen 2.35 Fr.
Ich war immer hier. Ich war mal
hier, da waren noch 26 Personen da:
24 Securitas,
irgendein anderer und ich.
Dann war es ganz dunkel,
also noch viel dunkler als jetzt.
Das war ein spezielles Gefühl.
10. März, am Abend.
Es war zwischen 18 und 18.30 Uhr.
Ich wollte eigentlich
nach Hause gehen.
In dem Moment
erhielt ich einen Anruf.
Der CEO war am Apparat,
Thomas Gottstein:
"Andreas, ich bin der Meinung,
dass wir
ein Unterstützungsprogramm brauchen
für die Schweizer Wirtschaft,
v.a. für die KMU."
"Arbeite mir bis morgen früh
einen Vorschlag aus,
wie ein solches Programm
aussehen könnte."
In der Nacht vom 10. auf den
11. März 2020 wurde in diesem Büro
der erste Entwurf
eines Rettungspakets der Banken
für kleine
und mittlere Unternehmen verfasst -
ein Darlehen über fünf Jahre
mit einem Zinssatz von 0 %.
Wir sagten: "Vielleicht brauchen wir
für die kleineren 100 % Garantie."
Aber uns war klar: Der Bund würde
das nicht selbst stemmen können.
Er würde die Banken brauchen,
und jedes KMU, jeder Gewerbekunde
hat eine Hausbank.
Es wäre schade,
wenn wir dieses Bankennetzwerk
nicht genutzt hätten.
So entstand diese Idee.
Ich sagte:
"Ja. Ist gut, machen wir."
"Woran hast du gedacht?"
Da sagt er:
"Arbeite einen Vorschlag aus."
Da war alles klar -
ich rief kurz zu Hause an,
ich würde die Nacht durcharbeiten.
Ich bot noch einige Kollegen auf,
und wir erarbeiteten das.
Am nächsten Tag arbeiteten wir
die zentralen Elemente aus -
natürlich etwas detaillierter
als hier geschrieben.
Wir präsentierten es
Thomas Gottstein,
und er sagte: "I like this idea!"
"Das ist eine gute Idee.
Darauf können wir aufbauen."
Ein Hilfspaket in Höhe von 40 Mrd. -
eine Zahl, die sämtliche Finanzkräfte
des Landes mobilisieren sollte.
Zuerst rief ich Mark Branson
von der FINMA an,
dann Thomas Jordan von
der Schweizerischen Nationalbank,
und dann Ueli Maurer.
Alle drei hielten es
für eine gute Idee.
Dann rief ich Sergio Ermotti an,
und der sagte auch, es sei eine gute
Idee, er werde sie unterstützen.
Wir haben heute
die Verordnung verabschiedet,
mit allen notwendigen Details,
damit man morgen
diese Gesuche stellen kann
und damit das funktioniert.
Ich erinnere mich an die Situation,
als Ueli Maurer
eine Pressekonferenz gab.
Wir waren schon fortgeschritten
in der Umsetzung des Programms.
Er sagte, der Anspruch von
der Schweizer Wirtschaft müsse sein,
dass diese Kredite
innerhalb von 30 Min.
gesprochen und ausgezahlt werden.
Ich dachte: "Ups, da müssen wir
noch mal von vorn beginnen."
30 Min. sind
eine ganz andere Zeitdimension,
als wir es sonst von der Art
und vom Zeitpunkt
einer Kreditfreigabe gewöhnt sind.
Wir schafften es
von Dienstag auf Donnerstag,
diesen Prozess
so schnell zu gestalten,
dass der erste Kredit
am Donnerstagmorgen, als es losging,
tatsächlich innerhalb
20 oder 25 Min. ausgezahlt wurde.
* Langsame, friedvolle Musik *
Diese Reha
ist für mich wie eine Wiedergeburt.
Ich muss erst wieder laufen lernen,
denn nach fünf Wochen im Bett,
dieser ganzen Situation, dem Stress,
den der Körper aushalten musste,
war es nicht leicht.
Ich habe Probleme beim Gehen,
aber das ist normal.
Ganz langsam lerne ich
gerade wieder das Treppensteigen.
Zum Glück bin ich noch jung
und mache schnell Fortschritte.
Das hilft mir.
Permesso?
Guten Morgen, Elena.
- Guten Morgen.
Wie geht's?
- Es geht, danke.
Wir haben
eine gute Nachricht für Sie:
Das Ergebnis des zweiten Tests
ist eingetroffen.
Auch der ist negativ.
Wir haben also zwei negative Tests.
Das heisst ...
Wie schön!
Was für eine gute Nachricht.
Die Dinge entwickeln sich gut.
Ihr Atmungssystem erholt sich.
Danke.
Das ist wirklich eine gute
Nachricht, ja. Ich bin so froh.
* Dröhnende, schleppende Musik *
Wie schön dich
nach so langer Zeit zu sehen, Mama.
* Schluchzen *
Für mich bleibt die Angst,
denn man weiss ja nicht,
ob die Antikörper wirklich schützen.
Und wenn nicht:
Wie geht es mir beim nächsten Mal?
Schaffe ich es dann?
Wird es nur eine kleine Erkältung
sein, zwei Fieberschübe
oder wird es mich wieder umhauen?
Ich weiss momentan nicht,
ob mein Körper das
in acht Monaten aushalten würde.
(Leise Durchsage) Das Zugteam der
SBB begrüsst Sie im Interregio ...
Während des Spitalaufenthalts
hatte ich das Glück,
dass Menschen für mich da waren,
sich nach mir erkundigten
und fragten, wie es mir ging,
oder die einfach sagten:
"Wir sind für dich da.
Wir denken an dich."
Und meine Eltern
waren immer für mich da.
Sie riefen mich an,
um zu fragen, wie es mir ging.
Wenn man müde und erschöpft ist,
wenn der Schmerz
auf der Skala bei 9 von 10 ist ...
Nicht immer, aber von Zeit zu Zeit,
kann es anstrengend sein,
immer auf die Frage
"Wie geht es dir?" zu antworten.
Wenn man vielleicht
so fünfmal pro Tag gefragt wird,
ist es manchmal ermüdend,
immer wieder zu antworten.
Deshalb entschloss ich schliesslich,
kurze Videos zu drehen.
Ich habe meine Erfahrung mit COVID
in diesen Videos auf Instagram
mit anderen geteilt.
So konnte ich mich ablenken.
Christian de Mestral
ist endlich von COVID-19 geheilt.
In der Zwischenzeit hat er
sein Medizinstudium abgeschlossen.
Er kommt aus Lausanne
nach Isone im Tessin,
wo er in der Kaserne eine Dienstzeit
als Arzt leisten wird.
Aus psychologischer Sicht
prägte es mich,
dass ich im Spital
auch andere COVID-Patienten sah.
Wenn man Menschen erlebt,
die Angst haben,
die glauben,
dass sie bald sterben,
oder solche
mit unerträglichen Schmerzen,
bei denen das Personal nicht sofort
eine Form der Linderung findet,
dann relativiert das einiges
und man denkt sich: "Gut, vielleicht
bin ich da doch besser dran."
* Gleichförmige Klavierklänge *
Man hat oft dieses Bild
vom Sieg der Medizin,
einer Medizin, die immer gewinnt.
Dann merkt man während des Studiums
oder im Laufe des Lebens,
dass das halt nicht immer so ist.
Manchmal kämpft man und gewinnt,
manchmal verliert man.
(Englisch) Heute treffen wir uns
mit den grössten Pharma-
und Biotechfirmen der Welt.
Wann haben Sie die Impfung?
Wann können Sie
mit der Produktion anfangen?
(Englisch) Danke für die Einladung,
Herr Präsident.
Stéphane Bancel,
ich bin CEO von Moderna.
Nur 42 Tage nach dem Bekanntwerden
der Sequenz des Virus
sandten wir unsere Impfung
an Dr. Faucis Team
und warten jetzt auf die Zulassung
der Impfung durch die FDA,
damit das Team schnellstmöglich
mit der Dosierung anfangen kann.
Sie haben also in einigen Monaten
eine Impfung? - Richtig.
* Antreibende, pulsierende Musik *
Wir verfolgen das mit Interesse
und einer gewissen Besorgnis,
aber ich glaube, dass die Schweiz
sehr gut vorbereitet ist.
(Stéphane Bancel, franösisch)
Dass wir auf eine Pandemie
vom Ausmass der Grippe von 1918
zusteuern,
erkannte ich
im Januar 2020 in Davos.
In diesem Moment beschloss ich,
bis zum Jahresende
ein zugelassenes Produkt zu haben.
Seit 2011
ist der Franzose Stéphane Bancel
Chef des amerikanischen
Pharmakonzerns Moderna.
Als er beschloss, sich
auf die Pandemie zu konzentrieren,
stand das Unternehmen
kurz vor dem Bankrott.
Zehn Jahre lang hatte es
kein Arzneimittel produziert.
Dann stieg Bancel
in den Wettlauf um den Impfstoff ein.
Zur gleichen Zeit
steckten sich in China
nach Wochen der Ruhe
wieder Menschen gegenseitig an.
(Mann) Moderna
ist sicherlich eine Biotech-Firma,
aber letztendlich
bringen wir als Lonza
das gesamte notwendige
Pharma-Know-how mit,
um solche Prozesse auch in einen
nächstgrösseren Massstab zu bringen.
Das ist natürlich
eine sehr schöne Synergie.
Monatelang arbeiten auf der Baustelle
der neuen Ibex-Anlage
von Lonza in Visp
etwa 1'000 Personen
rund um die Uhr.
Das alles, um bereit zu sein,
sobald der Moderna-Impfstoff
von den Schweizer Behörden und von
anderen Ländern grünes Licht erhält.
Hier war vor drei Monaten
eine sehr grosse Halle.
Vor drei Monaten.
Das wurde alles
in der kurzen Zeit aufgebaut.
Wir bauen hier
drei Produktionslinien.
Insgesamt sind wir hier in der Lage,
300 Mio. Dosen pro Jahr
herzustellen.
Wir stellen hier nur
den Wirkstoff des Impfstoffs her.
Das Ganze wird noch bei einem
Partner von Moderna in Spanien
in Fläschchen abgefüllt.
Mit der Produktion Visp und
auch mit dem Abfüller in Spanien
beliefern wir alles
ausserhalb der USA,
d.h. die Schweiz, Europa
und auch Kanada und Asien.
Hier befinden wir uns
im leeren Flügel,
wo wir
auf drei unterschiedlichen Ebenen
die Produktionsanlagen
einziehen können.
Das ist ein riesiger Bereich
mit einem Volumen
von fast einem Fussballstadion.
Wir nannten das immer
Hotelraumkonzept.
Wir als Lonza
haben die gemeinsamen Bereiche,
wir haben
die Infrastrukturversorgung,
und dann hat aber jeder auf jeder
Ebene sein eigenes Hotelzimmer,
wo dann Privatsphäre herrscht.
Vom multinationalen Pharmariesen
zu einem kleinen Schweizer Start-up.
Von Visp
nach Marly im Kanton Freiburg.
Das Unternehmen InnoMedica
hat seit dem Pandemiebeginn
aufregende Monate erlebt.
Neben der Forschung
an zwei Medikamenten -
einem gegen Krebs
und einem gegen Parkinson -
wird nun
an einem COVID-Impfstoff gearbeitet.
(Mit Echo) So.
Dann begrüsse ich Sie
im Forschungslabor der InnoMedica.
(Normal) Hier sehen Sie unsere
Arbeit der letzten zwei Jahre -
alles, was geklappt
und was nicht geklappt hat.
Und natürlich unser neuestes Kind:
die Impfung.
Mitte März 2020
haben die beiden Brüder Halbherr
und ihr Vater eine Idee.
Die Technologie, die sie erfolgreich
für andere Arzneimittel nutzen,
könnte auch die Grundlage
für einen neuen Impfstoff
gegen COVID-19 bilden.
Mitten im Lockdown versuchen sie
mit einem einfachen Zoom-Link,
das Unternehmen zu rekapitalisieren.
Mich hat sehr überrascht,
wie gut das funktionierte.
Am Ende
hatten wir 10 Mio. Kapitalerhöhung.
Im ersten Herstellungsschritt
haben wir die Hülle,
also ein Kügelchen.
Das Virus ist ja auch ein Kügelchen.
Im ersten Schritt
stellen wir dieses Kügelchen her.
Das haben wir inzwischen
extrem gut im Griff.
Alle unsere Therapeutika
basieren auf diesem Kügelchensystem
im Nanobereich.
Danach war der technische Kniff:
Wie kann ich die Virusproteine
auf die Oberfläche packen,
damit es nachher
aussieht wie ein Virus?
Das haben wir auf eine sehr elegante
Art und Weise hinbekommen,
indem die Virusproteine
über Elektrostatik
sozusagen an die Oberfläche
adsorbiert werden.
Der In-vitro-Versuch für
den neuen Impfstoff funktioniert.
Bei Mäusen klappt es jedoch nicht.
Meiner Meinung nach
hat dieses Scheitern
mit dem richtigen
Neutralisationstest
zu sehr viel
Innovationsdruck geführt,
sodass man sagte: "Okay,
wir brauchen wieder neue Ideen."
Der neue experimentelle Impfstoff
wäre jetzt da,
doch dem Kleinunternehmen fehlt
das Geld für klinische Versuche.
Noch aber hofft man in Marly.
Eine Zulassung wäre möglich.
70 Mio. Dosen pro Monat
seien realistisch.
Unsere Infrastruktur mit dem sehr
einfachen Herstellungsverfahren
erlaubt in jedem Fall die
Herstellung von genügend Impfstoff
für unsere Nation und wohl auch für
an die Schweiz angrenzende Nationen.
Hallo, hallo.
Okay, Pesche ist auch schon
unterwegs an die MET.
Du bist immer noch in San Francisco,
wie ich sehe.
Ja, ja, auf meiner Couch.
Salut, Tommaso.
- Hallo, hallo.
Bist du in St. Gallen?
Auf dem Mount Everest,
wie du siehst.
Wir haben jetzt
Medikamente erhalten.
Das ist aus Genf angekommen
und alles hat perfekt geklappt.
Das ist nun unter Verschluss -
das Placebo und das Verum.
Nächste Woche soll es losgehen,
dann rekrutieren wir
die ersten Patienten.
Wir können ins CHUV ...
Das Tessin würde sicher mitmachen,
St. Gallen und Chur
würden mitmachen.
Damit hätten wir vier Zentren.
Wie jeden Sonntag
seit dem Beginn des ersten Lockdowns
sitzen die vier Cerny-Brüder
am Computer.
Andreas ist Infektiologe in Lugano,
Thomas Onkologe in St. Gallen,
Erich Virologe in Genf
und Peter Radiologe in Bern.
Während die Aufmerksamkeit
der ganzen Welt seit Monaten
auf der Forschung nach
einem vorbeugenden Impfstoff liegt,
beschäftigen sich die Brüder Cerny
mit der Behandlung der Krankheit.
So kam ihnen die Idee,
ein Medikament zu entwickeln,
das auf Methylenblau basiert.
Die ersten Medikamente,
die wir bis bislang probiert haben,
sind antivirale Substanzen,
z.T. für andere Viren entwickelt.
Die haben eigentlich enttäuscht.
Wir können aber neu infizierten
Patienten bisher nicht viel bieten.
wir können sie nur beobachten,
und wenn es ihnen schlecht geht,
können wir sie hospitalisieren
und unter Umständen in
der Intensivpflegestation betreuen.
Der Anstoss kommt von Thomas Cerny,
dem Onkologen.
Er beobachtete, dass Kranke, die
mit Methylenblau behandelt werden,
um die Nebenwirkungen
der Chemotherapie zu reduzieren,
nicht an COVID-19 erkranken.
Da ist das
irgendwie zusammengekommen.
Wir sagten, diese Substanzen
sollte man sich anschauen.
Mein Bruder Erich ist in Genf
und hat Kontakte mit dem Labor
von Frau Professor
Caroline Tapparel.
Sie machte dann
die In-vitro-Versuche -
schaute also im Labor,
ob Methylenblau
gegen das SARS-CoV-2-Virus wirkt -
und stellte fest,
dass das hochwirksam ist.
Auf dieser Idee aufbauend machen wir
nun eben diesen klinischen Versuch.
In diesen Wochen besucht
das Team des Epatocentro Lugano
Probandinnen und Probanden, die sich
mit dem Coronavirus infiziert haben.
Eine Hälfte von ihnen bekommt
Methylenblau, die andere ein Placebo.
Die Ergebnisse der Studie werden
in einigen Monaten veröffentlicht.
Das Methylenblau
könnte unter Umständen wirken.
Es ist etwa fünfmal wirksamer
als das Hydroxichloroquin.
Wenn wir ein Medikament hätten,
das die ganzen Schwererkrankungen
verhindern kann,
wäre das natürlich
ein grosser Durchbruch.
* Langsame, schleppende Klänge *
(Koch) Jetzt ist ganz klar: Jetzt
sind wir in einer zweiten Welle,
und diese zweite Welle
betrifft die ganze Schweiz
eher stärker als die erste.
In der ersten Welle
waren v.a. das Tessin und
die Westschweiz zuerst betroffen.
Wir ergriffen dann Massnahmen
für die ganze Schweiz.
Die Deutschschweiz blieb dadurch
weitgehend
von einer schweren Welle verschont.
Eine solche Welle
macht den Menschen natürlich Angst.
Man würde jetzt vielleicht denken,
die Leute hätten v.a. Angst,
dass sie erkranken,
aber SRF gab kürzlich
eine sotomo-Studie in Auftrag,
diezeigte:
45 % haben Angst
vor der Erkrankung, vor dem Virus,
aber das sind weniger
als in der ersten Welle.
Aber 46 %
haben Angst vor der Vereinsamung.
Das sind wesentlich mehr
als in der ersten Welle.
(Cattacin) Die Angst nahm
in allen Bevölkerungsschichten zu.
Angst für ein, zwei, drei Tage
ist normal,
aber wenn sie strukturell wird,
besteht die Gefahr einer Depression.
Und es gibt deutliche Anzeichen
für ein gestiegenes Suizidrisiko
in diesem Zeitraum,
v.a. unter den jüngsten
und sehr alten Bevölkerungsgruppen,
denn sie
sind derzeit stärker davon bedroht,
dass eine Depression in schwere
Selbstverletzung umschlägt.
Das Portal Corona-Stress
der Universität Basel meldet,
dass schwere Depressionen in der
Bevölkerung von 3 % vor der Pandemie
auf 20 % Ende 2020 gestiegen sind.
Wir sind alle sehr besorgt.
Das sollten wir
wirklich genau beobachten,
denn die jungen Leute
brauchen soziale Kontakte
und Dinge wie Party machen,
sich abends treffen,
etwas zusammen erleben,
sich austauschen.
Solche Momente sind überaus wichtig
für die Persönlichkeitsentwicklung.
Werden diese Momente eingeschränkt
oder dürfen sie nicht
mit den notwendigen Emotionen
ausgelebt werden,
besteht ein hohes Risiko,
in ein schwarzes Loch zu fallen.
(Koch) Man wird sicher
irgendwann evaluieren
und eine Bilanz ziehen müssen.
Selbstverständlich
wird sich die Bilanz
nicht nur
darauf konzentrieren können,
ob man die Pandemie
gut im Griff hatte
und ob die Fallzahlen
nicht zu hoch waren.
Man muss wirklich
dieGesamtbilanz beachten.
Waren die durch die Massnahmen
entstandenen Schäden nicht zu gross?
Auch dort muss man schauen:
Hat man nicht zu viel gemacht?
Hat man nicht Schäden angerichtet,
die vermeidbar gewesen wären?
Diese Bilanz kann man jetzt
sicher noch nicht ziehen,
aber gerade
bei der psychischen Gesundheit
wird man das auf jeden Fall sehen
und auch berücksichtigen müssen.
(Cattacin) Diese Krise wird
unweigerlich Spuren hinterlassen.
Wie schwer die Auswirkungen
sein werden, müssen wir noch sehen.
Nicht nur auf die Wirtschaft
oder den Umgang der Gesellschaft
mit Rechten und Freiheit,
sondern auf die Menschen
und ihre Sicherheit an sich,
die stark beeinträchtigt wurde.
Ich erwarte
ganz klar eine zweite Pandemie,
die nicht
mit COVID-19 verbunden ist,
sondern
mit gesellschaftlichen Dynamiken.
* Langsame Klaviermusik *
SWISS TXT / Access Services
Meret Hachen, Daniel McMinn - 2021